so many of the issues and problems and  struggles and you know these like  existential crises and like even  envisioning the new earth and how we're  gonna build it and you know the timeline  it's like okay if you actually just go  into nature for like a day and get off  of the screen you get off of your phone  yes and actually allow your body to do  its natural process of healing allowing  your nervous system to just rest which  happens if you just step outside of the  city yes you see it clearly you know and  you can't help but feel connected you  can't help but feel you know activated  in your senses and your intuition can't  help but hear your inner voice become  amplified and I think that goes for all  humans you know like all of us is such  powerful healing and so imagine when we  were just living like that imagine we're  just living like that with no  obstruction you know just with the land  we can't help but be in harmony